au procès de jean marie villemin dijon
la parole et est aujourd'hui aux avocats
de la partie civile qui ont tenté de
comprendre les vrais mobiles de l'accusé
compte rendu d'audience dominique
verdeilhan gilles dollars j'avais du
chagrin dans les veines hier soir en
quelques mots jean marie villemin
demande aux jurés de le comprendre
je regrette mon geste leur dit il ces
regrets ne satisfont guère la partie
civile pour elle ce n'est pas l'heure du
pardon mais celle de la justice maître
prompt n'oublie pas de revenir sur la
piste christine villemin
durant ce procès insiste l'avocat
l'arrêt de non-lieu s'est effiloché
autodétruit maîtres prompt en chaîne
grégory est peut être mort dans une
bassine
il faudra que jean-marie apprennent à
vivre avec une énigme enfin pour le
bâtonnier hubert de montille le citoyen
ne comprendraient pas qu'un crime de
sang ne soit pas sanctionné
je pense d'une sanction doit être
prononcée parce que un homme a tué
barbe vengeance en se faisant justice
lui-même et parce qu'il était persuadé
atteint depuis la leucémie à coupable
dans la tête et la partie civile va
prononcer à cinq jours du verdict un mot
qui lui fait peur
acquittement maître paul prompt
s'adresse à jean marie villemin votre
acquittement serait la condamnation
posthume de bernard laroche
mais quel que soit le verdict vous serez
toujours un assassin une audience qui
illustre bien la complexité de ce procès
d'un côté un accusé en position de
victimes et de l'autre une partie civile
en position de coupables